hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one very
important question that Aristotle
explores with respect to the phenomenon
of achrafieh or a lack or loss of
self-control on a part of the person by
which they end up following desire
against right reason and doing the wrong
thing in the process is to what extent
is knowledge actually involved and this
ties in with a much broader question
running throughout the history of ideas
namely is it possible to know what the
good is or to know what wouldn't want to
do and while that knowledge is actually
possessed to not do it some people say
it's not actually possible that what's
going on there is the person really
doesn't have knowledge so in certain
respect they're not responsible you just
need to educate them further all the
moral theorists say no in fact not only
can people through that sort of thing
where they know what the good isn't they
they willingly choose to do the wrong
thing I myself have done you know when
Paul is talking for example about that
sort of thing that's an example of a
cross yet there's plenty of other
examples of people as well so Aristotle
is interested
does the ax cratic person knowingly do
what is wrong and he's going to say yes
then the question is well in what sense
do they have knowledge he's going to
dispose of another question before those
why we're also talking about opinion or
dosa he says it doesn't really matter
whether the person is is assumed to have
knowledge or true opinion as Orthodox up
why doesn't it actually matter he says
some men hold their opinions with
absolute certainty and take them for
positive knowledge I think we all have
experience of that so that if weakness
of conviction be the criteria for
deciding that men we act against their
conception of what is right must be said
to opine rather than to know the right
then there would really be no difference
in this respect between opinion and
knowledge so we don't want to just you
know conflate opinion and knowledge on
the basis of say strength you know the
strength behind the conviction that a
person holds those with knowledge should
be convincing opinion should be less
convincing but quite often we see people
who don't have knowledge at all they
just have the whole bunch of ideas bunch
of the lease and they stick to them as
if they knew them sometimes it's because
they have gotten them from a source that
they consider to be knowledgeable but
it's really just opinion that that their
home so when you re psychology today and
you read an article about a psychologist
about what you know neuroscience has
revealed to us you're not a
neuroscientist so you don't actually
know if the summary of the study is
actually accurately depicting what the
study is most have demonstrated
presumably the authors of the study
possess knowledge hopefully the author
of the article possesses knowledge of
what's being talked about there they're
not actually communicating knowledge as
such to you and if you're relying on
that belief and you're saying I know
that the neuroscientist
that's really more an article of faith
or opinion dokes ah than anything else
here's a little says that doesn't really
matter we're not going to worry about
that so let's just put them put that
issue aside are there cases in which we
actually do have knowledge but we do the
wrong thing that is we give in to desire
rather than following what our knowledge
the knowledge of what would be good in
that situation would tell us what is
that reason is telling us Aristotle says
yes and he outlines for ways in which
this can occur some of which look at
awful lot like each other so I'm going
to do my best year to try to distinguish
them apart from each other the first one
is he says we can have knowledge but not
actually be using or attending to or to
use the word that he's actually
employing they're contemplating that
knowledge the arraign it's the same word
that we need a theory from or you know
we translate as contemplative or
contemplating we might have knowledge
but we not we might not actually be
looking at that knowledge as relevant in
that situation and so in one sense we do
have the knowledge it's at our disposal
but we're for whatever reason perhaps
were daydreaming or we're attending to
other things or stress has caused us to
you know focus in only on one part of
the situation we ignore the knowledge
that we actually do possess and hand
ready at our disposal Aristotle himself
talks about this by saying the word no
is used in two senses a man who has
knowledge but it's not exercising it is
said to know so as a person who's
actually exercising that knowledge so
let's talk now about the second and
we'll come back to the first when we get
to the third another possibility and
here Aristotle is talking about moral
reasoning or
practical reasoning and he's touching on
some technical terminology that ties in
with what we call practical syllogism
I'm going to shoot a separate video
specifically about that where we talk
about how that fits into Aristotle's
understanding of practical reasoning in
any case we have general or universal
terms and promises in moral reasoning
the practical reasoning and then we also
have particular terms or or premises and
these are supposed to lead us ultimately
to some sort of conclusion now what
would be examples of universal terms or
premises the most universal I suppose
would be something along the lines of
the good is to be pursued or the good is
to be done and evil avoided right what
are particular terms I should hold on to
this book because that is going to be
helpful for me this book me those are
particular things this book will allow
me to perform might ask well right we
have a particular thing there and we
said well who cares about that I don't
care that it would help you perform your
test well and in another premise it is
important for me to perform my cash flow
we can add in multiple ones if we want
it but other point is is that he's
saying that we are in these sorts of
cases employing the universal are the
general terms but we're not actually
using the knowledge of the particular so
we're not reasoning correctly we're not
applying their knowledge to the actual
case that we're facing or to ourselves
as individuals great example of this if
I am a person who is struggling with one
of my vices then Aristotle has SAT
previous
nikka mckean ethics it's probably a good
idea to kind of swing to the other
extreme to aim towards the other end of
the spectrum and so you might wind up in
the middle so there could be things for
myself like for example we could say hey
it's perfectly fine for people in
general to do this say to get into anger
right when it's for the right amount you
know the right amount right person right
reason all those those sorts of things
that go along with me prenups for me if
I'm struggling with anger it's better if
I don't give in to anger at all that's
an individual thing about my case it is
also about general things but it's less
general than the human condition in
general because it has to do with people
who are say struggling with a vice or
struggling specifically with anger there
could be things that apply that I won't
attend to if I don't pay attention to
the particulars of the situation so
they'd craddock person might be behaving
at chronically because although they
didn't have knowledge of the general and
then you have knowledge of the
particular they're not actually using
knowledge of the particular and so
they're going to reason wrongly now the
third one I said it was sort of like the
first one and we're going to try to
differentiate those a little bit he says
not using knowledge in some cases
knowledge that we possess happens
because of a state that we're in so he
talks about for example being asleep
being insane or suffering from a mental
disorder of some sort meinl minim we're
being drunk and these are all Aristotle
thinks not merely states of the psyche
they also have physical correlates when
we're asleep we're actually bodily
sleeping when we're drinking that's a
great example where the body clearly
does influence the mine because it's
drinking the alcohol that causes us to
have
different psychological condition right
being being insane for Aristotle he
seems to see at least in this respect is
something with a physical coral he says
then that people under the influence of
passion our passions are in the same
condition these are the strong emotions
he says it's evident that anger sexual
desire and certain other of these
passions actually alter the state of the
body and in some cases even cause
madness extreme cases right so he says
it's clear that we have to have we have
to say that the unrestrained or you know
lack of self-control person has
knowledge only in the same way as men
who are a sleeper mad or drunk and he
goes on to talk about them actually in a
kind of automatic way using the language
of knowledge think about your drunk
friends when you're trying to reason
with them and they're arguing with you
and you can get into a long conversation
about what they're arguing about and is
generally you know poor reasoning or
sometimes even incoherent but they are
talking like somebody who actually knows
with what's going on and can reason and
can pull the conversation with somebody
else so how is this different than
number one with number three there
appears to be some sort of physical core
like going on that is impeding the use
of the knowledge that the person has it
is similar in that you have knowledge
that you're not attending to or using it
but this seems to be just more generally
or perhaps in cases where it's not due
to a passion it's not due to be drunk
it's not due to being half asleep sleep
deprived any of those sorts of things
the fourth one is similar to the second
in that it's also bringing out the
practical syllogism that it is the
instrument for moral reasoning or
practical reasoning and he says that we
could actually have two different
practical syllogisms you know this is
metaphorical in our heads at the same
time that is operative for us at the
same time and we we should be listening
to one of them more and now to the other
one and if we were you know really
thinking things through without being
steered by desire then that would do
that but unfortunately desirey adds
weight to one side of the balance and
one of the practical syllogisms then
gets listen to and the other one that's
sort of contradictory to it or at least
has conflicts with it in some way
doesn't get listened to and we just sort
of going to lose sight of it and then we
follow the first one so we are carrying
out a process of reasoning but its
reasoning that is guided by the wrong
desires now that's not to say that that
the other one wouldn't also be guided by
designer Aristotle thinks that desire
plays a role as we've seen in his
philosophy action in pretty much
everything but what he says about this
is when people fail and self-restraint
they act in a sense under the influence
of a principal or opinion but one that
is not itself in itself but only
accidentally opposed to the right
principle it's the desire that's really
opposed so this is you know again one of
the ways in which we do quite often go
on just because we happen to have
reasons or as we often say rationalize
doesn't mean that we're actually doing
the right thing so each one of these is
one of the ways in which it's possible
to answer yes to this question does the
ax cratic person knowingly do what is
wrong yes they know in one sense no they
don't know in another sense though the
knowledge is not being completely
operative or the knowledge is being
misused in some way there's a lot more
that could
be said about this but that's probably
enough at this point to give you a small
over